the human body is a complex network of
cells tissues and organs that together
make life possible ten major systems are
responsible for the body's functions
skeletal muscular cardiovascular nervous
endocrine lymphatic respiratory
digestive urinary reproductive the
skeletal muscular cardiovascular and
nervous systems in particular create an
infrastructure that facilitates the
other systems the adult skeletal system
is a framework of over 200 bones they
hold the body together give it shape and
protect its organs and tissues the
skeleton also provides anchor points for
the muscular system which includes three
types of muscles skeletal smooth and
cardiac they are found throughout the
body and facilitate movement nestled
within these muscles is the
cardiovascular system a pipeline that
includes the heart blood vessels and the
blood itself also called the circulatory
system the cardiovascular system
delivers oxygen white blood cells
hormones and nutrients throughout the
body
lastly the nervous system is a
communication network of nerve cells
that the body uses to transmit
information and coordinate bodily
functions it's comprised of the brain
the hub of sensory and intellectual
activity the spinal cord and the many
cranial and spinal nerves that emanate
from them this infrastructure created by
neurons blood muscles and bones allows
three other systems to regulate the
body's environment the endocrine
lymphatic and urinary systems the
endocrine system is a series of glands
that use information carried by the
nervous system to help regulate the
body's processes
thanks to this neural connection
endocrine glands such as the thyroid are
aware of the amount of hormones and
other chemicals they need to produce
these chemicals are then distributed
throughout the body by way of the
cardiovascular system the cardiovascular
and nervous systems are also utilized by
the lymphatic system a collection of
lymph nodes and vessels that help
regulate the body's defenses also called
the immune system the lymphatic system
uses neural pathways to transmit
information about affected areas of the
body and then sends out healing agents
like white blood cells via the blood
stream
another key regulatory system is the
urinary system which includes the
kidneys ureters bladder and urethra the
urinary or renal system maintains the
body's electrolyte levels and filters
waste from the blood this waste is sent
through the blood vessels into the
kidneys and then expelled as urine all
of these systems require energy to
function and that's where the
respiratory and digestive systems come
in the respiratory system is a group of
passageways and organs that extracts
life-giving oxygen from the air we
breathe air enters the body through
nasal cavities travels down the throat
and is then transported to
lungs the lungs extract oxygen for the
body to use and then expel a carbon
dioxide by-product when we exhale energy
can also come in the form of food the
digestive system is an approximately 30
foot series of organs that convert food
into fuel food enters the system through
the mouth then moves into the esophagus
the stomach and the intestines nutrients
are absorbed into the body while solid
waste is expelled through the anal canal
the end of the digestive tract
no matter the roll size or shape of any
of the body systems each began with a
reproductive system this system is
responsible for creating life
the primary organs involved differ
between the sexes with ovaries fallopian
tubes the uterus and vagina found in
women and testes and a sperm channel
found in men together fertilization may
occur organ systems form and then a
child is born humans are complicated
organisms but when our 10 major organ
systems are healthy they ensure our
well-being
[Music]
you